in this video I'll be introducing the
rational numbers and set builder
notation the rational numbers are
defined as a ratio of two integers and
examples include the integers themselves
terminating decimals and repeating
decimals so let's start with repeating
decimals if we let 10x equal nine point
nine nine nine repeating then if we
divide by both sides by 10 then x equals
zero point nine nine nine repeating and
if we subtract X from 10x we have 9x
equals nine and then divide both sides
by nine we have x equals one and then if
we multiply by ten both sides by 10 we
have 10x equals 10 so now we have 10x
equals 10
but 10x also equals nine point nine nine
and repeating so we have now and these
are in fact true nine point nine nine
repeating equals ten so we think we can
now express 10x as an integer which is a
rational number we can put 10 divided by
one which is a ratio so another problem
we have is terminating decimals if we
have two point seven eight equal to Y
then we can just easily say 278 divided
by 100 equals y as well these are two
integers and it's a it's another
rational number
so a convenient way to define these is
denoted with a Q and this is called set
builder notation we have the Q equals
the set containing elements a divided by
B such that a and B are elements of the
integers when the only condition that B
cannot equal 0 if you divide by zero its
its undefined it doesn't mean anything
so if you're interested in that I
recommend googling it I think it's
interesting